she probably definitely kicked her
[Laughter]
[Music]
so today i am going to go through kevin
hart's instagram and let's just see what
he's been up to that's what i say
so
wow there's already i live
i live any time kevin hart and dwayne
johnson are around each other
oh my god this one is a picture of him
um the internet will forever be
undefeated this is hilarious as hell so
i guess somebody i don't know if he
like found it and did it but it's
somebody has superimposed
dwayne johnson um holding a baby and
it's his kevin hart's face
is on it
which is awesome this is funny god if
you haven't seen jumanji it's so great
what's happening here
oh my god i love this
um
my my thug wait hold on wait wait
my thug pregnant wife
um she gonna kill me for this
too funny though
like spread eagle and some pants and
like full-on pregger tummy i get that
though i look like we have all looked
like that like well first of all no i
did not look that good so
congratulations but i did have the shirt
up just itching just like get out like i
want you out of me um i she probably
definitely kicked
[Laughter]
it's awesome though
okay what is this
here's a video so
oh
shoot
i'm on tick-tock now
why
well i'm doing a tick-tock honey so this
has to be how you do take top
i like this i'm on tic tac now
[Laughter]
dad stop you know what it does you know
what i love about that it doesn't matter
how cool and famous you are in the
public eye your kids still think you're
lame a lot of times
it's awesome
i'm with them i don't know how to do it
either um so i relate to that but this
is the one i really need us to just
focus in on
what is happening
this makes me laugh
hashtag nailed it
happy halloween
peep the napkin under my elbow
[Laughter]
oh my god i hope you're gonna zoom in on
this okay it's amazing it's an old
school picture of um
of dwayne johnson just rocking a fanny
pack
and a girl chain and just has randomly
some kind of napkin under his
and just holding the fanny pack it's
just really great duane it's really a
good look um
and the best part is is kevin dressed up
like it
those two are so funny
i love them so much
um yeah let's comment on this one
turns out
you no one can make a fanny pack call
it turns out
let's just write that turns out
no one can make a fanny pack cool again
or was it ever is the question
glow's going to kill me my makeup artist
wears a long time she looks cool though
so
but ken and then didn't pull that off
um let's see what's happening here
saturday mornings be like
gets the photo cred oh she gets the
photo cred oh it's just everything this
is true
everyone's on top of everybody
somebody's playing a game
little one's trying to yeah
i love that he has doberman
makes me miss i used to have a doberman
um cairo
everyone this is pretty funny though
because everyone this is so life like
the kids are totally being entertained
by something it is what makes saturdays
beautiful for parents sometimes i'm like
watch
okay well wait i have to end with this
she got me wrapped around her finger
already okay this is adorable
oh my god his little one is so cute
seeing a dad a little it says and down
to baby that's adorable i love that one
all right this was what i was deep
liking um and i went in on kevin hart
today he's funny y'all no one is shocked
by this
um but i i'm just gonna leave you with
this image
from jumanji
um
one of the individuals in this picture
was scared of
the scene that particular individual
thought they were going to get hurt
because the other individual was a kung
fu master as a child luckily i held back
[Laughter]
that's amazing
i love it if you haven't seen jumanji
i'm just going to leave you with this it
was such a great both of them were so
great anyway i love kevin hart
alright bye y'all
[Music]
you